okay hi everyone welcome to another
wolfram language
design review language completeness and
consistency
uh discussion
about a variety of topics starting with
leaf count
okay proposal leaf count should take a
heads option yes i believe that to be
the case
right so that's just sort of
background material about
you know users have asked us
and confused
we can't change the default
right i i don't and i don't think we
should
um okay so what is the question yeah
well
um
[Music]
so well when i originally prepared this
agenda i guess i didn't know my
lightning would be stolen by a previous
meeting so
if if you agree that we should have it
then that's great but then there's also
a documentation
some documentation
related issues which are in the next
section
gosh
well we've clearly got to enhance the
documentation
right so i have you know some suggested
notes that uh on uh you know tentative
on the page
um
or
real should be rational right
uh yes that's uh
that wasn't a bad r substitution
right so replace the current node with
one that says ordinary expressions and
then sort of clarify
um
well you should say for ordinary
expressions leaf count is based on full
form representation okay
for raw and other atomic expressions
the leaf count is generally one
i i guess we can right because
uh association is
uh
technically
atomic it obeys atom q but it is not
right it doesn't have a leaf count of
one
why is it considered atom cue
because it is
it's not a normal expression it right
it's it's some data structure that we
provide a sort of a fake full form for
and also you know rational and complex
are
uh
so the full form is just going to look
like this
yes but if you do adam q on that
you will you will get true
right there there are several kind of
low level
expression manipulation functions that
just kind of mysteriously don't work or
work in weird ways on associations
but many work as you would expect
yes
although bubba and sort of support for
each one needs to be added in the video
that's kind of weird already i mean you
know because that that is not
giving you
you know part one of this
exactly
um
do you know i think association is also
hold all complete isn't it
yes
so the association is lots of unexpected
uh
properties
why is it hold on wait a minute
but if i say
association of oneplus one here
it'll run
right
but
do
uh it does it under its own control
go ahead yes exactly
and if you do something like uh
um
right but if you if you
had that association and you did you
know slash dot
blank goes to blank squared
it would not evaluate
right or like if you do replace all you
know
yeah
yeah a goes right that doesn't work
that's an example of one of those things
on general expressions that doesn't work
on associations
i wonder whether we document that in um
well either an association or in slash
dot
um i think it's the same like cases also
i don't think searches keys and stuff
like that right so uh certainly
uh there are you know i think i have a
list somewhere here about
or at least the start of the list that
there are other places where we need to
make this
uh thing that we only operate on the
values right because like level like
right only sees the values it doesn't
see the keys right because
uh remember back when we used to
what what was it that tally called it
the
the
not the grand principle he had some name
like that the central dogma the central
dogma thank you
right so right that they're they're
they're really lists it's just that
their parts are expressions rather than
the numbers and so because of that we
have all these
all these functions which only see the
uh
the values and not the keys
right
all right well okay fine is there any
more to discuss here i mean
leaf count why don't you just say leaf
count whenever is it the case that
atom q if atom q is true it usually is
the case that leaf count is one
but what are the counter examples uh
rational complex and dissociation
okay why don't we just list those well
they are listed in the next two notes
yeah okay fair enough but maybe just a
table i mean just so people don't i i
okay so so just uh
uh
you know maybe with the following
exceptions
all right i'll i'll play with that
fine but i think this is otherwise seems
good
and um
is there any other issue i mean heads
true false
that should just do it right
i i think so um
okay
all right are we on to the next item
yep
right so we talked about
uh sort of deprecating
the fact that
options can take a stream name as a
naked string
and
you know then tree the string as a
as a possible symbol name
yup
and so this is sort of uh a proposal
about
um
and with maybe a couple of questions in
there um
why are we doing this
why are we doing what if it's neither a
string nor a symbol and why isn't
options of you know
you know
blah blah blah
just an error
because it's documented to do something
which it says right there
the this is consistent with the the
documented usage of options of blog
gives the explicitly listed
options in the expression
okay but it's not explicitly listed if
it's options or plot or something
that's not exactly well right so symbols
options right
what
you know so options of
look at the input right the right the
right look in the
in the list
in the example right above the one right
that's just some general function f of a
right and it gave you exactly the things
that are options in there wild
i had no idea that worked it's probably
worked since version one and it's been
documented for certainly since at least
version six if not version one so your
point is
i mean you're saying i mean if it's a
normal expression i understand what it
should do
if it's a symbol it's doing this special
thing and if it's a string
it's right now also doing a special
thing
right wow
okay i mean
it could error out if it's a string
i mean
if we're going to the string as an
alternative to symbol
here couldn't it just error out if there
isn't if there aren't options
i mean what you're saying is that if i
say options of f of a b
this is going to return nothing right
which is perfectly nice behavior for a
normal expression
but given that we're going to have the
special case behavior with a single
symbol
why wouldn't we have special case
behavior with a single string too
what happens if i say options of
that's correct that's right
yeah it's an inert object
what if you know the case
that you know the string is neither a
stream nor a symbol
yep
are you thinking of the case like
you do it for a string that could be a
symbol but isn't in the symbol table or
something that couldn't even be a symbol
name in the first place
interesting
okay what happens if it's just a bunch
of spaces
right well
so that's the current behavior um what
are you proposing for this
um well
again i i i
right i
favor simplicity simplicity so i would
just continue to return an empty list
for that and what would you return for
options of
quote capital plot
i mean are you proposing to do something
with that
you mean
yes that that is the proposal
that will be equivalent to options of
plot the symbol so how would the context
be chosen
um
i guess well uh
i guess
based on context path i presume right i
mean it would it should be more or less
the same as options of symbol of the
string
i know maybe this so are you creating a
symbol to do this or does it well in the
symbol table
no it has to be in the symbol table
right so this is this this is just like
uh i think attributes
right attributes takes
right so whatever it is that attributes
does we would extend to options
let's see what it actually does
it's not doing that
well
it's looking for a symbol named a bunch
of spaces in the symbol table
and it doesn't find any so
but it doesn't create anything it
doesn't create anything no if you did
attributes of x that assuming you don't
currently have
assuming name queue of the string x is
currently
false then there would be no symbol
created after
that's a whole point of these guys
okay
all right so what's the question here so
the question is
so so are we okay with the sort of stage
one stage two um well yeah let's do
stage one let's see if there's any freak
out okay right and there's a question of
um
[Music]
should
should stat air and stat air issue
messages or should since we're not
planning on dropping support for those
those should just quietly continue to
work
what's the what's the better way to do
that
well you you'd have to
write construct output stream of
stat air comma one or whatever the full
form of
right to do full form of dollar streams
and and why on earth did we not have
something because you know we just
why don't we have a dollar standard
output
dollar standard error
i mean i think we were relying on that
30 years ago
so we have streams of standard out and
the thing about that is it returns a
list because i guess it thinks that you
can actually have more than one
um standard output in standard airstream
well well if you had a file open called
stat out dash foo i think it would
return it maybe i'm wrong or maybe it
just chose to
to always return a list for uniformity
boy it um
i remember i mean it's just there's one
of these things where somewhere deep
inside you know it's like these
technology stacks where somewhere deep
inside there's something from just
absolutely
i don't know there's probably a great
example of this of some
some technological thing where
where just
there's a something which is there for
compatibility with the thing that's been
gone for a hundred years
and that feels like what this is
i mean it's like we're we're doing this
sort of super
well okay i didn't even know that this
was called stood out
as the output stream here
so why exactly do we not have a symbolic
name for this
as an alternative
so that one can think of
well i mean you know what i'm saying it
seems like this is a very primitive
you know version one terminal interface
type thing
i vaguely remember that we do
so now um oh dollar output is that what
it is
oh yeah no
output is a list of output streams to
which you should send output
ah and that's the thing that i thought
was a list of all the standard outs okay
because you could see that it's a list
of standard out right right but
particularly
you can
you can append to the point of dollar
output is you can append to it and then
write to multiple files at once yeah
yeah okay okay and and then and then my
comment was going to be correct me if
i'm wrong there's no analogous dollar
error
there's dollar urgent i think it's
called yes
okay
i mean oh that goes to stood out yeah
i think you could set that to be stadera
i don't exactly know what happens i mean
if i say how do i even do this if i say
right
to
studera
and i just write a string or is it right
string
presumably it went to this
standard error which is probably
disembodied because it's
you know this is a kernel that was
started from
by the front end and therefore
you know stead air is not attached to a
tty
that's a very deeply lost animal
i mean so what you're telling me is if i
go
and i go here
what the heck is that
oh for goodness sake nothing ever works
growl
how could that be wrong what is that
even
okay in any case
let's try it here
okay so now if i say
right string
oh wow
okay right because
right because by default uh stood out
instead there are both attached to tty
now but if i said
two or something right
or whatever it is
yep
what the heck is that
i don't even imagine what that is i
thought i was quitting there who knows
okay in any case all right so fine so
what i'm arguing here is that we should
have
um
[Music]
i mean maybe we should call it dollar
output stream dollar
standard output stream standard error
stream
that make any sense who's just whose
value is just output stream has stood
out output stream of studera
i mean it's just typing more stuff but
it makes it a little bit less kind of
crazy
unix you know string
right except yeah right the the argument
for keeping stead instead of is backward
compatibility oh no no we should have
the possibility of accessing things that
way i'm just saying that this should be
a symbol name that we can document that
that is equal to output
okay so if this is uh and also not in
instead of then i'm i'm fine with it
right i'm suggesting it also what do you
think of the name standard output stream
standard error stream
i i think those
are are the obvious names is there is
there no standard in there is the
standard input stream
there there
is exist
right now it's got dollar input
um
oh god it's nothing there okay so if i
run standard input
um
is that just the input like if you run
the command line program like that's
just the input
yeah i think that if i run it
if i say i don't know how to quit from
here i thought it was control d
if i say
c right and then well while he he what
happened is you hit command d rather
than control d and you split your
terminal is
what happened before
but
um
oh i see
oh control command yes okay fair enough
okay pipe
that to that
and then no actually what i want to do
is cat
that's not what i want i want cat dollar
input
you'll need to put single quotes around
the dollar input
ordinary quotes yep
still empty
maybe just look at the example for
dollar input if you really want
no no i but i believe that if i read it
from a file it would be the file name i
think
yeah all right i think i think right i
think that's the point that it's not uh
attached to uh
to uh you want echo instead of cat
yeah because cat failed not yeah yeah
yeah yeah oh right yes you should go
through and deal with the dot m's here
that's just a note please for project
management
um
ah in dollar input file name avery
points out that's right that's the file
name
as opposed to the stream name
right because
dollar input file name is set
um if you just do a get
yeah you know it's just outrageous that
we get have all these for goodness sake
can we please try to could you point
this out to avery could you point this
out to the documentation folk again
yet another thing that's version
specific
make sense
yep got it
well this is a very old
my god this is a version two i thought
this was version one
um
okay i mean anything more to say about
this
i'm not sure how important these are but
they would be things that might be nice
to be able to document
for as we get more and more useful from
engine and more and more actual use of
our
uh
you know of things which are essentially
low level command line operations
okay any more to say about this so the
question is whether to give an error on
standard if you stood out in stadera
i would say let's not give the error for
now yep
okay
okay
are we on to the next thing yep
linear solve function
all right so this is a question that was
sent to
tlcc
um
is it yan or
i don't know what language is
um
you can bind all kinds of different
names to the same object
okay i mean i've asked this question
various times you know i've never
understood our matrix
decomposition functions
i you know it's always been like well
people packed these matrices this way in
the 1960s and everybody's doing been
doing it ever since
yes
what is the
right okay so so so i i'm perfectly
happy to discuss that question but i
will point out that that is a different
question from the one that's being asked
here so the question you just asked is
why do we return this crazy thing
instead of two matrices an l and a u
b which is i mean certainly not
everybody still does that like i think
matlab gives an l and a u they don't
pack them together
um and i agree i mean i think for
usability reasons we absolutely do want
the l and the u separately we still
would need in general they were the guys
who were like it was the fortran
tradition
yes
you can't represent a triangular matrix
in fortran
um right
the linpac
which was the
very very original implementation of
these linear algebra routines
the upper and lower triangular matrix is
in a single matrix because it was it was
a waste of space back in the day to put
them separately nowadays we don't have
the space issues so it makes sense
okay but let's understand first question
is
the idea of a linear solved function
right where
don't we have
i'm sorry i'm now confused
we don't have a linear solve function
now like we do there it is what what
that exact that that example with n29
should just do linear solve that same
input
that's what i thought i thought we had
yes yes
yes but but the question is suppose you
want to compute your own decomposition
for whatever reason
i mean john claims that he has some
faster algorithm
at least
or maybe you want a slightly different
form
you want to you want your own favorite
permutation
um
[Music]
right then how do you go from that data
to a linear solve function
is why do you want to i mean so okay
first question is who uses value
decomposition disembodied from linear
solving
does anybody does anybody care about
that
i think
i think it's pretty much there as a
pedagogical thing
and so i think it's a standard tool you
can use it to compute
uh various things you get two triangular
matrices we could
actually triangular matrices now perhaps
you don't get triangular matrices now
we don't write
no no i mean
my question is do people want this as an
endless self yes yes yes
okay so what do you do with this other
than just admire it
you can the determinant is is you can
just look at the the
um
the the middle entries you know you take
the product of the diagonal entries
that's right you you've pre-done a bunch
of computations that you can then reuse
but that's the whole concept of the
linear solve function but
sure
but people don't people don't quite get
that idea so
right well also linear solve function
doesn't actually show you
a diagonal you can just read off
well you can you can
i mean it has these properties which
which you know are way before steven
allowed properties that so they're not
really documented
which properties well we don't document
them because because
it
solve has of the first matrix and then
yeah so instead of x y z you do
properties there
i think you'll see that oh my god
you need to close your quote i know that
oh
right yes it's got lots of hair this is
before you you actually
you we had a way of setting up
properties at all that that was
considered documentable oh that's the
ghetto as opposed to the get noah
right which should be lower right or
something yeah
sure i mean we could we could set those
up and document them nicely
well the fact that there's a lower in
linear solve it's just i mean whatever i
mean i don't care how linear solve works
all i want is something where i can
repeatedly solve with an equation
well
it's not it's not really a curry format
i mean this actually creates something
called the linear solve function
yeah i realize right but but um
down in our live stream is suggesting
why doesn't led composition return an
association
yeah i mean it could do that but but if
we had a mechanism
to get out
from a matrix
you know i mean look we could call it
for example i mean because we have to
hack the design at this point
in a sense we're lud composition data
could give one
with a property name here or
alternatively a um a curried form
could give one or all just early
composite decomposition data could go to
an association
that has all of those things
does that make sense
i
i suppose i mean i'm not sure how
interesting the function that is
well you guys are telling me that this
is um
i don't think we are telling you that
but why is this coming up okay we've got
an led composition function people say
output
okay so so well
it's first of all written right there
stephen
um
the question that's come up is if you've
computed your own lud composition for
whatever reason how do you turn it into
a linear solve function
then there's the other question of how
should we package up lu decomposition
better and i think
you know what people would expect from
that is an upper matrix and a lower
matrix and possibly a permutation yes
fine but we can't change the output form
value decomposition and i agree with
that which is why i've suggested like an
lu decomposition matrix or something
like that or exactly i don't know what
we call it this
i mean led composition data is what i'm
suggesting for the thing that you're
describing there
but
i don't think people would want i
i don't think the market that is served
by giving an l and a u is served by by
giving
an association much less one that
includes the condition number
well i i mean i think
right
i don't have any opinion about that i i
you know you told me pedagogical
purposes where would i get the
permutation for example if i've got the
if i've got a list of matrix no it's
going to be as obscure
to get
you know for example
if i had if you get a list which is a
upper diagonal matrix and we'll have an
upper
upper triangular matrix type so you'll
see upper triangular matrix of blah
lower triangular matrix of blah and then
this other thing which is the
permutation
so
so you're saying right now we've got two
things two somewhat obscure things that
are coming back in led composition what
we want to do is break that guy i don't
even know what that one is what is that
one
remember that is the presentation and
what's
it's an estimated condition
which only works for i think
approximate real approximate reals like
machine precision or move the others
right
yeah
whoo
okay
so that's a bizarrely packaged object
yes we i think okay but to get the law
and upper triangular can i not say of a
matrix just lower triangularized yes i
can well it's lower triangularize
minus one plus add the identity matrix
of the correct dimensions
why don't you look at the low at the lu
decomposition rough page
and then you'll see how painful this is
um
that's painful
is it really that
uh
this looks like an old version of the
documentation but uh
version 30 no i mean uh
how old is old
well
that that looks like a pre-130 it's
basic examples to me
uh sorry but i'm running
open the
actually i'm running the prototype type
which has some ancient build apparently
okay well fine so let me open this and
then the more recent i mean the more
civilized version
it's got a time machine
there we go that looks better
somebody should check on the thirteen
one prototype build
and its documentation
i can do that
okay
right so that's how you get l you lower
triangularize minus one and you add in
an identity matrix of the correct
dimensions
aren't there various other matrix
decompositions like sure decomposition
and so on do they also produce these
bizarrely packaged results no this is
only this one
why
i mean
so
so the reason is
because before we had linear solve
function we had this function called l u
back substitution
and
l and l u decomposition gave output in
the form consumable by
lu back substitution
right so maybe the answer to jan's
question is he should use the obsolete
function lu back substitution
well you can also you can also plug it
into linear solve function
using the using the full form but that's
a bit of hackery
okay what problem are we trying to solve
here we're trying to solve the fact that
we say that in modern times we think led
composition should have been designed to
return explicit upper and lower
triangular matrices
that that is one question that is not
the question that john originally asked
that sparked
this agenda item but
that is a related that is another item
that i'm happy to discuss and is
related
certainly okay so the the the question
here is given this weirdly packaged
thing in led composition how do i make a
usable linear solve function out of it
correct
you're right and
assume that i don't want to start from
the matrix because i've have my own way
of computing lu decomposition that i can
turn into that form how do i then
further feed it to linear solve function
well well the linear solve function
makes the assumption that the the ldd
composition is in this packed
uh l.a pack form
so
so it's so if you have a packed form of
a matrix you can put it into and then
you solve function
i mean not not not in a documented way
but it's certainly possible
okay so the question is could linear
solve function take
i mean un
uh
validated linear solved functions
could they actually just take as an
argument
a single argument that is
essentially some kind of value
decomposition output
yeah it probably could do
it seems like a very very very corner
case
right it's a corner case i think that
could work here's here's another
possible idea for the led composition
stuff is right now led composition is
one argument right
um i believe suppose we put in a second
argument and say
you know the default for that was you
know quote packed quote or something
like that
and then we could have you know uh
the possible thing would be the list of
matries to put out like
lower upper
and and the default would just be to
return this pack thing to be consistent
but then we could we could return what
we wanted
like an association for example like an
association right
okay but that doesn't that solves the
other problem
of
different output
from
uh you know like linus
led composition of
of thing
comma quotes matrices
might give the lower and the upper
yes
right
okay
but so the remaining problem
is is there any way to go from a
hand-built led composition
to
uh you know into the linear solve
function strikes me i mean just
yeah if you could if you do if you do
linear solve that input
and do input form
you'll see you'll see you could you know
it would be easy enough to plug it in
gosh i wish when nobody had defined an m
here that then is not used for anything
else
well it is used in the next
import
i don't me i mean why define a variable
and make it something which you cannot
do in one shot
right so
under input form of that
and that
that thing the two comma true and then
the stuff following that
that is the output of the lu
decomposition for that well it isn't it
is not this part here is that part is
the after the true yep
gosh i wish this bracket clicking worked
in input form
wouldn't that be nice
wouldn't it be nice yes i
if if if you surround input form uh with
the list then i believe it will work
are you serious
um
i'm serious that that that is my belief
i'm not sure that my belief is correct
but
my golly god
golly gosh yes
right because because
in in one case right you your
excel is input form so you end up in
text data whereas here it's inside so
you're in box data
that's obvious but i never thought of it
yes
why don't we ask john volts if he can
just make it so it works this way i mean
yeah
just because you can also do shift
command i on
that output cell and
then it's genuine input form so i mean
the issue is that there are well look
the real point is to just make double
clicking work in input form
which could be done
and it should be on the user assistance
yes
i'll let john replied to that point
okay
okay
uh
all right so i think this is a deep
corner case and i don't think we can be
serious about it i think being able to
take something linear solve eats i think
the idea of having additional string
arguments to led composition sounds
highly sensible and i think we should
just figure out how to do it
okay make sense
um right there was this
additional question about
why does it never save the factorization
for rectangular matrices
is it is that just
lazy oh the reason the reason for that
is because the factorization
you know the factorization doesn't
really
isn't really proper for singular
matrices so it goes back to the
basically what it does is it goes back
to the
linear solve thing which resolves it in
various different ways
so you're saying led composition doesn't
make sense
for
rectangular matrices is that what you're
saying
and linear solve has other ways to deal
with it nonsense then yourself has other
ways to deal with that yes
so in particular if i were to make this
comma 5 6 here
that's really funky
right so what it's doing is it's
destroying the original matrix and then
it
you know it goes back to whatever
you know so this is preserving that
linear solve of law of argument is
equivalent to
you know linear solve of blah comma
argument right but it claims there is no
optimization here that can be made for
repeated use
i think that's
that that's not completely correct but
it's to be consistent to be consistent
probably not
well i don't understand here i mean
whoops
why
usually you would need to use least
squares instead of linear result in
cases well dude yeah if you
if you do the transpose you have a much
better chance of having a consistent
okay all right okay fine but my question
is
okay what are you saying i mean linear
solve should do the best it can to
save something which can be used for
repeated solving
is it not doing that
no and that right that that
basically the only thing you can do for
cases like that is check it for a
particular argument there may be a
consistent solution but there's no
decomposition that's going to work to
typically find that
i'm sorry could you say that again
okay so
with with that singular matrix there may
be a particular
x y and z for which you can actually
find a solution
okay you cannot in general
but it depends very much on that x y and
z so so there's not a single
decomposition that's going to tell you
whether it's going to work for a given x
y and z okay
so there's no general there's no
optimization what you're telling me is
there's no pre-caching of a
decomposition that will be useful for
repeated solving of a rectangular matrix
there could be in some cases but but
again
you know those are those are rare and
you could spend you could spend
you know years trying to figure out
those cases and keep it consistent with
what linear solve does which i think is
a is a marginal prospect
okay fine all right okay all right so i
think the the only conclusion from this
is that led composition needs additional
property arguments that can give a
variety of matrices matrix lists of
matrices
other things
any other issues here
nope
okay
then let's do it
okay
okay
manipulating held expressions
okay
there's a lot
of issue here
basically there's a bunch of stuff with
the compiler
which which also needs a different
mechanism for
well
i don't know exactly what this item is
but there's a bunch of stuff with the
compiler that probably relates to to it
but yeah okay
let's understand
what the real point is so we have a
symbolic expression
and
in
i i can give all kinds of physics
analogies to this but in our environment
as soon as you have a symbolic
expression
it will start evaluating
we can protect it by putting protective
coating around it
of a hold
to prevent evaluation
but then as soon as we probe into the
protective coat
all bets are off
right that's the issue is what what do
you want to have happen inside the
protective coat and we've got this
inactive mechanism which is an attempt
to
micro protect different parts of the of
the machine
and inactive by the way i mean inactive
would be very very close to i mean it
would be able to solve lots of problems
except for the fact that it has this
glaring hole that it doesn't inactivate
atoms
oh boy well should we have a version of
it activate that does inactivate atoms
and it's that okay let's just understand
from a theoretical point of view i mean
back in the in the dawn of symbolic
computing people thought well first of
all most people had a one-pass evaluator
you know eval was just a one-pass thing
i actually was a mess because functions
were multi-paths variables for one pass
and so on
but so
in a sense an activate
could
recurse down
and just wrap every little sub piece
in coating
that's what it does right now but only
for normal only heads
right right that's the version we threw
away we had a version like that that was
useless that we threw away many years
before
well okay so
right and and
right and of course inactive things are
not completely inert right if you
if you take the
curl of an inactive grad right you'll
end up with zero
because we can pre predict what the
result of that action is
right i mean you can apply things to the
outside i mean just like you can apply
length to an active expression
you know
but i think that's what you want
but clearly the thing isn't the same
thing
right it's been it's been wrapped
right so the issue is
the issues that i mean i'm interested in
what this older version was that wrapped
more stuff because i mean i think it
makes total sense that like okay it
shouldn't max it shouldn't wrap strings
it shouldn't map numbers stuff like that
it shouldn't wrap certain things that it
knows are inert i think but i think what
the the problem
the problem we tried to solve with
inactive
was to have inert mathematical operators
we have active operators and we wanted
inactive operators in other words you
can represent an integral formula
so i'm saying that they represent the
problem you can represent an equation
with an inactive solve
and that itself is a mathematical
expression and operator that you can
manipulate
okay transform guys look
the thing we would like to have
is a notion of a symbolic expression
where nothing has a built-in value
we just take this symbolic expression
it's a it's an expression it has lengths
it has this it has that
but nothing in other words you've got
some some object some expression and
it's as if for the compiler for example
there could be an expression there and
the expression in and of itself does
absolutely nothing eval is nowhere in
the loop
right so i i get that for for for
program transformation and there might
be more that you want like storing
annotations and properties along the way
and things
right so the issue is
we could have a i mean right now our
internal
so one way to do this which again i mean
there's just so many things that are
crazy okay so let's let's give an
example so let's say we have the
inactivated version or i shouldn't say
inactivated the um
uh
yes the passive version
of um
uh well it's the look look it's the
the symbolic symbolic expression
there
okay
and and that symbolic symbolic
expression is
you know
plus of times of three comma two comma
one for example okay
okay that's the symbolic symbolic
expression now i want to test
you see so one thing i might imagine
doing is just putting in these in a
different context
for instance okay
but the problem with that is what if i
want to test you know find
you know i want to find the position in
that of times
or if you want to evaluate it
well yes but i mean and does position
work with unevaluated
quite possibly
listen listen the problem is
as soon as you have the expression and
as soon as it hits the main part of the
system as soon as okay you know we have
an infinite evaluation system
it is on a you know a hair trigger for
any expression it's always going to just
start evaluating it reminds me greatly
of physics
um
you know you don't get to have a a um a
sort of a static structure of space that
doesn't do anything
but
so we we are in a sense
you know but nevertheless
there's nothing wrong with a symbolic
structure it's just that
we have this evaluator that's a really
grabby evaluator that's coming in and
trying to do things with these but but
if it was kind of a string-like object
this is this is what drives you crazy
let's imagine that we had this thing was
in a pseudo string
okay i don't know how i'm going to
represent the pseudo string um
i don't know you know whatever it is
this is a pseudo string let's say
okay
and um so then it is just a thing you
can pick up you can look at it you can
do
but but it on of itself go ahead what do
you mean do things to it because i think
the issue is that the issues that if you
have an operation right
the way reverse works is that it's like
you know you apply it to the outside of
an expression that transforms the you
know that whole expression when it
evaluates sort of gets replaced with
another expression which then of course
you know evaluate i mean unless i mean
this is i think the issue is that you
can have things that are held and you
have certain functions that work you
know through the whole like replace all
and stuff like that but if you want to
be able to run reverse on your held
expression you know reverse needs an
actual
implementation
that that you know doesn't evaluate its
output stuff like that
well
okay look one question is well
let me make two points uh one is of
course the issue reverse doesn't
evaluate its arguments at least if you
you know
if it's uh hold of blow or you give it
unevaluated it's just
the evaluator sees the expression has
changed and starts evaluating all over
again but also just you know deciding
whether you've matching something can
run code and i have that example there
with echo false and f of and the
function f right just deciding whether
or not
things match can produce evaluations
right and i and i don't think there's
any way to solve that other than just
being careful okay but but you know the
point is the level of compiled code
there is a notion of an expression data
structure
that is completely inert i mean it only
does things when you poke it with
uh
you know when you actually do compiled
operations on it
well i mean it's the same internal c
code right and this is the right so
for those who are aware who are aware
this is the issue the compiler right now
is that it has history you you went you
went caved
is that better yeah yes okay yeah so so
the issue with the compiler is that it
it has an expression type which just is
the kernel c code expert and so of
course if you do something to it
unless you ask it to evaluate it's not
going to evaluate so you know you can
run reverse on on your your you know
your unevaluated expression and it will
reverse it but it will still be
unevaluated just like kernel c code
so
i mean the issue is that i mean one one
option with the compilers to make
another expression type that
where you know functions like reverse
will actually explicitly ask that their
output be evaluated before returning it
so it'll actually have the same
semantics at the top level but in any
case the the version that doesn't
evaluate that's like kernel c code is
itself pretty useful
and so right so maybe the answer is we
we need a function that usually converts
things to that and
to walk
to walk to this to the right so they're
so i i
i wasn't expecting to go in this
direction though we might need tom or
some such but right there is
there everyday they have well i guess
rob's here so rob can tell us right but
right there is a a an expression level
representation of expressions that's
used by the compiler and that's where
all the
magic happens that's right but that see
this it's actually as it is now i think
christopher's absolutely correct we need
we need different
different levels of things that evaluate
first for example it it's very hard to
use right now in the compiler because
suppose you
suppose you have something that you want
to represent an expression you say do
you know do you know call times on that
so so set up multiplication well
um
you know what what happens is you don't
get the properties you expect out of
times namely it doesn't doesn't create a
number
um it creates a new expression with head
times or something like that so it's
it's
and there are different levels you know
it's it's it's not right now not totally
thought out so it's not consistent with
what it does with times i mean should
times
just create a new expression or should
actually try to try to do numbers and
you know our actual times has all this
code which is deeply enmeshed with the
evaluator that you know merges numeric
constants and integers and stuff
together and
so it's a it's you know so how do you
switch up think is a little easier which
i suspect is part of what christopher is
after
so a long time ago i implemented my own
c
structure expert structure
long before i started the company
and part of the reason that i needed
that is because i needed to sort of
extract things from it without it
you know blowing up from the evaluator
and that i could do
have the correct complexity of doing
that i could traverse to the you know i
could look for many things by traversing
at once and things like that
and that that is super hard to do with
the with the uh with the current sort of
expressions i don't even know how to do
it in top level
i know that's exactly what we're talking
about roger i mean what we're talking
about is a raw expression
right but i think what one can do is
kind of extract data from it like
searching it and finding things in
positions and things like that
but
when you want to interleave that with
what rob was just talking about like a
little bit of evaluation
and when you try it becomes super
difficult i think well it's like a
string okay a string does nothing unless
you poke it go ahead yeah i mean
here's a weird example right i mean so
you can imagine having something that's
like kind of like an expression but it's
marked so that you know
so it's imagine we had just like a a
flag in the sea extra struggle this is
not i'm not proposing it's a terrible
idea but imagine we had a flag against
the extra structure that would tell it
not to evaluate when you call you know
eval on it
um
then you'd imagine so the question is
you know certain functions that are
written in c they could work just fine
right and and then you but but now
imagine like how how would a function
with like a down specified with a down
value work
right so where where you know you input
one of these
non-evaluating expressions and it gets
ripped apart and its constituent pieces
get put in 15 different places in this
new expression and then what those
ripped apart pieces will sit unevaluated
where everything around them evaluates
and
you know it just becomes very very hairy
very well and then occasionally then you
have to ask the question are two
unevaluated x's the same
are they equal are they same q
you mean because one of them might have
evaluated earlier when x was equal to
two and the other might have evaluated
like for example you have a five yeah
sure
yes right
right but if it's a true symbolic
expression the obvious answer is yes
right
right i'm just saying that like you know
the the the point is is that
i think
you know if we had something you know
the point is that we like to think of
stuff like hold as being like you know
this outer rapper and so on but there
are functions that will you know rip
apart the expression and evaluate these
parts and not evaluate those parts and
move things around all sorts of ways so
that the part that was originally inside
of the hold may be
ripped up and moved into 15 different
places
and and you know
and so it's not as simple as just then
returning another held expression
because some parts of it will you need
to evaluate other parts don't etcetera
right i mean i guess inactivate kind of
does some of that because at least lets
you have sort of bits that are
unevaluated
but
but yeah
yeah i mean i i think inactivate
inactive using enact i never use
inactivate but using an active around
certain heads like i've constructed you
know compiler code often by using
you know inactive of compound expression
and you know various things and then
activating it
inside the function
i don't i mean i don't think inactive
itself is that useful uh
a tool
but in i mean inactivate is not a useful
tool but inactive by itself where you
put it exactly where you want is quite
exactly yeah i think that's the main use
case we have actually well right but the
the thing about the thing about atoms i
mean inactive is great but inactivate is
the only one that
i think is problematic that's the one
that doesn't that you know if if an
activate put an around a taunt you know
x
then
then i think it would be pretty are you
sure are you sure because i think that
if it did that
that all kinds of comparison things will
get weird all kinds of depth counting
things will get weird i mean we're using
a hack that basically heads are not
usually gone down that's really the hack
we're using
and if that head
i mean i suppose if if you have
what happens to curried forms do we put
the inactive on the head of the head of
the head
i don't think so but i think that would
also be good
well okay but i mean christopher what
what
do you have an application in mind
because it it it might even if the
general case we all get lost
we we do look listen it does put it on
the head of the head of that oh never
mind yeah
okay look
i i would like to say that i think
there's a general thing which is just
meta programming of you know just
manipulating code just i want to do
transformations i want to do pattern
matching transformations on code i want
to replace a for loop with a table for
example how do i do that i've got a full
loop sitting there
and
you know in a piece of code
and maybe it's in a notebook
maybe it's just in raw code that i read
in and now you have to you're right to
ask how did i get the code in there
without it evaluating well that was kind
of my use case from when i wrote what i
did also yeah
you know i mean i was writing compilers
basically so the the
um
but one of the things that is missing in
that is that you need to build a model
of assignment and state
uh if you're going to look at that level
of generality
and that
you need a little bit bigger machinery i
think to do that realistically you need
to model state transitions well okay so
your claim that's true if you're doing
if you're doing that level of analysis
but i think that there's more basic
stuff i mean there's more basic stuff
just around around just moving
expressions around where you don't want
to have to sort of tip toe super
carefully to make sure it doesn't
evaluate and you don't forget
for the more basic stuff do you
essentially just want something that's
like hold form like it looks like the
expression but it's invisible to the
function above it in the way that
unevaluated is
like it doesn't no because you go
look because you extract things and it
auto wraps them in something
so that
it just looks like the expression but it
wraps it in something so that
expressions don't get evaluated well the
problem is when does it do the wrapping
let's say you're doing pattern matching
does it leave it pre-wrapped when you're
doing the question mark when you're when
you're doing the
pattern would match just the underlying
expression but the
result would wrap it right and let me
point out that the moment you do blank
uh underscore you know blank question
mark odd cue you've lost the game
right because there's no way that oddq
can ha no oh this is a special type of
expression so i shouldn't allow
you know the one plus one to evaluate to
two
exactly i mean this is the this is this
is i think we sort of started with which
is that you know i i think this is sort
of the difficult
thing is i think that what the sort of
behavior that you'd like that you're
sort of expecting
is to basically have a whole
you know whole set of implementations
for all these functions like oddq and
reverse and so on that are sort of
implementations that know that they're
going to be eating some unevaluated
thing and that they know not to try and
evaluate it
right
but but i think that's that's sort of
and again
i mean maybe some of those can be can be
sort of stolen from the compiler because
the compiler basically has a bunch of
you know such implementations as well as
things that kind of exist in kernel c
code but i'm not sure that's the best i
mean you know it this is such a losing
thing because the fact is as soon as you
say plus one you've got something you're
trying to say
is this equal to that plus one
and yeah
you know then it just isn't going to
evaluate the plus one it's just gonna
sit there right exactly and that's
that's that's what i was saying was the
problem with the stuff in the compiler
now you do a plus one you expect it to
be a number and it
it may or may not be this unevaluated
thing which then you have to go and
check
and well that's what yeah right it
becomes really hard right you know
you know that's why people
you know what does in a repel for
example how many times do you call a
vowel i mean do you do a valid l
available until you get to a fixed point
that's effectively what we're doing all
the time
okay so let's think about this i mean
the issue is
okay
we've got these
blobs of unevaluated data
that are symbolic are inert symbolic
expressions
i mean i i suspect the basic point here
is that we have to do a bit of heavier
lifting some somewhere we're going to
have to do something that isn't
i mean okay what will be the perfect
version of the calculus of inert
expressions
i would claim one possible perfect
version
is
it's called times
but it just isn't
it's well okay to what extent is it like
inactive of times maybe it is just like
an active of times
am i making sense i mean in other words
what's the difference between
what i'm okay what what does an active
not do so i think the problem is that
inactive doesn't preserve the whole
attributes so take an example that i use
a lot which is some
so some has
hold all attribute
but if you do inactive of some to stop
some doing its thing now suddenly it
lets its arguments evaluate
may i make a meta meta comment about our
discussion here basically there are
all kinds of leaks
in this boat
and you know jose is pointing out one
leak
christopher is pointing out another leak
i mean okay so
leaks
in the inactive boat
well
yeah we thought about going down the the
path of allowing attributes to be
inherited by the inactive thing and and
eventually decided that was a bad idea
right
symbols are not wrapped
underneath the same problem i don't
think we want to
to prevent symbols or to wrap symbols if
if if
some preserved the whole attribute then
its symbols inside would not evaluate
well i understand i understand that
those are those are slightly related
problems i'm just saying i believe there
are many leaks in this boat
yeah i i think that the symbols one i
think is actually i would argue is
slightly more fundamental because the
problem with that is that if you call
inactivate on an expression
and then you activate it again and
specify that like it be held as you
activate it like if you just remove all
the inactives
it'll actually be different because
it'll have evaluated things
right
but like
i mean if you have a hold all function
or something and you inactivate it and
then you sort of you know get rid of the
inactives it'll still be the same thing
the problem is just that if you try and
if you yourself write an active sum of
blah blah then you'll have a problem
which which is a legitimate issue though
and yeah of course we haven't even
talked about scoping although i think
that happens at evaluation time not at
first time so
maybe the that's somewhere beyond
okay let's return again to the problem
that we actually have okay so i want to
you know
use cases right and the major use case
is meta programming
so i've got four
i don't know how to write this
for i equals zero you know i less than
10
i plus plus
you know echo
i or something this is a bad idea this
is such an unbelievably bad idea okay
and let's say now i want to do a code
transformation to this
okay
now what am i going to do how do i do
this what would you advise me to do to
do that code transformation
should i do an activate of this
i mean
i would wrap it and hold and and and use
replacement rules
i agree yeah first will that work i mean
but but yes
if i wrap it and hold
that so you see if you if you try not to
change the 10 to 100
and do a rule replacement
it's not going to be trivial
and we have tricks if you just do
um well if you do 10 goes to 100 that
will work that's easy
it's hard
exactly do integers go to integer square
high goes to hours so x underscore
integer go to x square
so that inserts that
10 to 100 right
then 0 squared and 10 squared
instead of 100
right and of course there are ways
around that but
exactly and
yeah you need a with a condition okay
okay so it has to be lexically done so
there is no i mean one thing here there
is no
uh
evaluation
whatever it is delayed
you know delayed exploding evaluation so
to speak
wait do you mean something where you ask
or place to evaluate it immediately
yes
yes i.e
i.e
a version of replace
that evaluates upon replacement
so
i think it would be a special right-hand
side yes
i imagine it would be a wrapper on the
right-hand side
okay so then then this would be
immediate evaluate
right evaluate always
or or something
right but you know i thought steven was
talking about the problem of
transforming that
from
you know a four to a table which
you know that's pretty straightforward
to do because you don't need to evaluate
anything you just need to
match the pieces and rearrange them
right
um is it really straightforward i mean
so okay so that's not realistically
because there ends up being issues about
like you know oh well does you know if
it's just i is less than 10 it's fine
but if it's i is less than anything else
but i don't even know how to change the
four i don't know how to get the pieces
out
hold pattern right of
oh god
i think it's easier to be inactive
yeah
yeah by the way another another note is
of course the inactive one if you take
the inactive one and do slash dot 10
goes x goes to x squared
then that that one will work
okay so here
right
blank integer
goes to x squared
yes that only works because of the
non-wrapping of atoms
right but that's because you know it's
right it's not you know nothing is going
to explode in your face because
zero is going to get evaluated it also
works because of the thing jose was
complaining about if we if we had you
know i think four is i can't remember
full four as hold all
uh to begin with and then it processes
stuff or not but but if we respected the
hold then you can't do transformations
like this inside some if we get right
but
but certainly modules
yeah exactly but that's that's what
allows me to use inactive of module
effectively because i can evaluate stuff
inside as i want
um and then get the expression
you know as it is if it was hold all
then it would be completely useless
right i mean i don't really understand
what
you know
i mean should that should that not work
that case we just did above i mean i
don't really understand what the
alternative is well i think it's great i
think it's great that it does
christopher that's one of the that's one
of the things i think that
that makes inactive useful maybe maybe
we could maybe we could have an option
or something to inactivate that would
that would go ahead and wrap
wrap symbols and atoms and stuff like
that
right yeah
do we treat symbols differently from
other atoms
and of course there are yeah there are
some atoms that we technically
ignore right like sparse array
uh right i mean i don't think it looks
at adam q it just looks under the
expression yeah no that won't i was
gonna say that won't work because
[Laughter]
you have to say inactive of four
as a headdress
then then it would be an activity and
also an active yes and then also you
need to use inactive on the increment
and maybe on the less than yeah yeah
probably on the set yeah well
you may remember
well i i suppose he could try using
ignoring inactive and seeing if that
right if you use the full form of
replace all there is the ignoring an
active
option which may or may not help in this
case but
it's why there's a reason about so i i
can't tell you if if it will or not
what do you mean it's good
is it is that not an option to no we did
we decided against doing that because
that involved changes of the pattern
matcher which proved to be pretty much
impossible
okay
um so yeah one of your thoughts even was
to have have us have an option to ignore
inactive
inside the pattern matcher but
but
you know i discussed it was calm and it
was impossible
oh it's it's a headdress uh that that's
my right ignoring inactive is a
headdress so if maybe if you'd wrap
ignoring and active around the whole
left hand side of the pattern
then maybe
that yeah that's where i that's where i
got confused so ignoring inactive
yep of inactivate
yep
but it didn't help so
i think the problem is that the blank
you know x blank is is inactive of blank
isn't it
yeah that right you may need to do like
an acceptable verbatim of blank in your
inactivate but i don't know what on
earth is that why is that exposed still
blue for example
um
[Music]
i know that might be a small front and
bug uh
um not actually a fun dent because blank
of it's it's inactive a blank of expert
not blank of expert
or yeah i i don't think
i don't think the front end is that
clever
but maybe it doesn't know about it
an activative x-blank
is still it's not
rodentifying inside the x-blank
oh that's bizarre
yeah it is
oh no it's not no it's not that's
totally bizarre
that uh so
uh
no pattern is probably in the excluded
places right
what is their way of accessing the
excluded list developer back they can
activate exclusions uh we wanted to
promote these as system symbols and and
stephen objected
um
so today what is it called dollar
inactivate exclusions
oh my god
right and so
so it's
so symbol ones means so these are
ordered pairs if the if the second
argument is symbol it means don't wrap
this in an active but head inside and
look inside of it
and expression means
if you if you see this guy then just
stop right there this is a
you know this is a quote-unquote data
expression which
shouldn't evaluate
although that's very dangerous because
you know b-spline function
who knows what's in the b-spline
function it could be a you know you know
right it could be literally anything in
there
like i guess this is the this is the
thing that's okay i guess this is the
issue with inactivate it's just the fact
that i mean trying to be a little bit
clever about what it's gonna hold and
what it doesn't
but but the thing is it's like if you
imagine you know if you imagine writing
a program where it's like uh
you know
you're writing an api and someone gives
you a piece of code and then you need to
check it and make sure it's safe and
then you might evaluate it or something
but like
you absolutely cannot do that with an
active because they're just so many
holes where where crazy stuff could
happen
yeah yeah
right and and and and you know as roger
was saying earlier the point of inactive
was to allow you to do math like if you
literally wrapped you know every two and
every x in an active
then
it gets hard to sort of talk about
you know this integral
okay let's zoom out again
the main problem that we have is that
eval
is just
you know eval is everywhere
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to have expressions where
okay we got two problems i i claim there
are two fundamental problems
okay basic problems one
eval is everywhere
and two
is
times
is the same i shouldn't say times i
don't know plus
is the same plus
should be the same plus everywhere
so in other words we can't really have
it there's you know in other words if a
vowel is everywhere
we can't say that the plus
we could have a different plus
that was immune to our standard of vowel
but then it's a different plus
as soon as it's the same plus
eval is everywhere
now we could imagine okay question
could we have a different main loop
that's a very scary thing to say yes
right and of course yes i was going to
add right it's not just eval it's also
subs eval or whatever it's called the
thing that scans down values and applies
them one at a time
or all sorts where which is where most
evaluation leaks unintentional
evaluation leaks come from
what would a main loop unfortunately
this follows my my meta theorem of
evaluators the only evaluator that does
nothing wrong is an evaluator that does
not say nothing
yeah
um
and you know a main loop who's evaluated
does nothing
i mean that's kind of like what the i
mean well that's kind of like how it
works both in kernel c code and in the
compiler where there's basically no main
loop
yes right when you apply a function it
just produces a new expression and then
that's it there's no you know it's done
right the question of course relies on
the fact that the implementation of
those functions
doesn't rely on the loop being there
which most functions do
well a lot of cases so so that's that's
one of the big differences as somebody
who writes a lot of kernel c code still
um and have for a long time that's one
of the big difficulties in writing
kernel c code is
sometimes you want to call some other
function but but you always have to
check whether that function expects
that things have been evaluated or not
and if you call it when it's expecting a
valuation and you haven't evaluated
you're typically going to get wrong
results in
very unpleasant and sometimes very
hidden ways
right and yes and saying that right
saying that there's this sharp line
between c code and
i mean it is technically true
that there is but it's a bit misleading
right because some c code
function you call may itself call eval
to process
some portion of its arguments of course
absolutely right italian that's very
that's that's very common what the c
code allows you to do
is manipulate
basically
it allows you to manipulate the
expression tree and then evaluate when
you want to
right
hmm okay okay so it's all yeah so so
it's trees so it's ian's problem
i'm done
well you can make asps from everything
but that's not that doesn't really help
us
i mean it might a bit but yeah yeah we
could use the compiler asd stuff to
to do something but i don't think that
here's another thing i think that's a
bit of admitting defeat is if you know
we have this beautiful exper you know
expert code is data thing and then we
say well actually we can use this data
structure to move them around right
okay turning everything into asts is
just a more
you know is basically a more extreme
version of inactivate
um i mean if if we turned everything
into asts okay so then the problem with
that is
then we need
you know new versions of every function
of every relevant function
to operate on ast expressions
okay here's an idea here's an idea okay
what if there was a thing
this isn't quite a well-formed idea
it's kind of like an activate but
yeah i mean in if you have a function
clearly
which is dealing with an activated stuff
you can always say activate
to take the thing that was inactivated
and activate it so to speak so in other
words if you have
inactivate of
uh you know one plus one plus one plus
one plus one
okay
we're hopefully inactivated there
and now we say
uh
inactivate no well oh thank you activate
that's why i thought it wasn't turning
all purple
i mean all brown
um okay so activate
that does activate have have a um any
kind of um
oh wow oh i muted i was muted i was
telling you right both inactivate and
activate take a pattern of heads to
inactivate or activate which is you know
okay so then then in this case what i
could do is i could say
um
plus
of blank blank oh god this is not going
to work is it
no because it's matched against the
heads
so you could do like plus or times
but
all right and that was so
i see for which that matches that
okay so if i say
okay so if i say inactivate that and
then i say times
activate that with times
whatever
right so times evaluated and flattened
right right
wasn't any flat thing i mean it was just
oh yeah i guess we we removed yeah which
is why it types it differently
but i think what you want here is not i
mean that
you know it's it's easy to give the head
level control but probably what you want
to do is you want to
activate some
some part of that expression right
yes probably after a replacement
we talked about
uh
i know if avery can find it because this
was like two
project managers ago but i think we
created a ticket about
extensions to activate and inactivate
which
it was long enough ago that then we
didn't have anybody to to to work on it
at the time um that i don't remember the
details but we may have already gone
down the road of
designing some extensions to activate
and inactivate which i know maybe we
want to reconsider now but a possibly
useful function might be something like
activate
part
yes
i i definitely had by the way a um
a thing does anybody know what it was
expression unevaluated expressions maybe
what's it called i definitely had a
thing here for this
um
yeah i mean so look we're going to
something is going to have to do some
heavy lifting here we're not going to be
able to get away there's no
i think there's no you know
there's not going to be a trivial answer
because again we have i mean you know
arguably we could you know arguably
people who've studied programming
language semantics
in a in a different world from the one
in a parallel universe
where such people had actually studied
symbolic programming sometime in the
last 40 years
this might have been properly studied
but i don't think it has been
um
the i mean you know there's probably
basically theorems that basically say
you can't get everything you want yeah
um
but
but i mean again
the real thing we want to be able to do
is this meta programming you know
you know
manipulating code
oh we've got a thing called code
transformation ah look at this we've got
held code code transformation
health code 02 2016 only five years ago
six years ago
evaluate in place evaluate at
goals
in certain evaluation before processing
that's the things we're talking about
here apply evaluated use evaluated okay
so map out evaluate in place
so that's essentially what we're talking
about right now
i think
there are
this project has two parts the part of
making a function not evaluate so much
and the part of
making a function evaluate inside held
expressions instead of getting stuck as
it happens right now and and these
things is the second part
so
we have seen we have seen the example
that i gave at the beginning of of
something doing a check and uh
evaluating too much
i think that's a separate case so
so this is the second idea of having a
health expression and doing things
inside
i'm sorry can you repeat that because i
got a bit lost
yes so you started showing an example in
which you did a check
and it's evaluated
and we didn't want to evaluate
and then there are all this second part
of you have a health expression and you
want to do things inside
and we saw the example of the rule that
got
the square inside but didn't evaluate
the square yep
i think that that's the part that we
have explored several times
and that's why we need an evaluate at
and replace add and things like that
so this is
rule delayed evaluate
yes
so you see it's the same construction i
was mentioning before how to evaluate a
number inside something which is held
yes
right okay so you're saying
you're saying rule delayed
evaluate which could either be
something it could either be i don't
know what you know
it could either be something like
um x arrow x colon greater than
immediate evaluate
of y or it could be its own rule delayed
evaluate
right
right but the semantics which we
understand fairly clearly are
you go in there
and
i mean the problem is that everything in
the light cone so to speak in the future
like cone of the immediate evaluation is
evaluated
if you understand what i'm saying so if
there was something there
where you know when you picked it up
inside that expression you said well i
only want to evaluate these pieces then
you've still got a different problem
right which with uh
you know that problem i i i have
sometimes if if i'm dealing with
user-defined functions you you can and
you want to evaluate sort of one step at
a time you can hack around that by
instead of having the function but
replacing uh with you know down values
of the head
right and that'll do sort of one replace
one level of evaluation for you
but in general yeah getting you know you
want to
val you wanted to completely evaluate
the function you gave it but then not go
into infinite evaluation i don't i don't
know how that
i don't know how to solve that problem i
don't know that it is solvable you know
down in our live streams mentioning
template slot which we indeed have not
mentioned
and and we have a rule condition which
is what internal is used to solve this
problem but it's not exposed
what is rule condition
so do you see on your notebook on your
right
what it says with trick
so that's the notation we use
to force the evaluation inside which
internally gets converted into root
condition
oh the with trick i i didn't understand
what that meant here's an example of
rule condition further up
oh yes
what the heck is that
some internal
details
i mean it's some internal implementation
detail of the pattern matcher which
you know happens to do the right thing
in this case
and i know maybe it's generalizable but
you know
uh it's it's it's not like it was
designed for this express purpose
no but it it solves that one of the most
important problems in all of this
which is
justice
evaluating things inside hell
expressions
right
evaluating things inside health
expressions after replacement
after exactly
but there are other things you might do
for example well okay so
okay and so you're saying that would
apply also to replace part in a held
expression
and then you could use the same kind of
construct
you know part three goes to immediate
evaluate
of whatever
right so rule condition right wouldn't
work there because that's not really
pattern matching
right it's pattern matching against the
indices not pattern matching against the
expression what else would one want to
do so so what about map for example
because map can go down the expression
i mean you know if we said map at blah
blah blah
map at f
and then we've again on the held
expression
we might want to have a you know map at
of some kind of immediate
immediate version of f on the held
expression
i mean in general
any function
that can kind of spray
another function
into something
and how many functions are there that do
that
are there millions or are there only a
limited number
and i mean those are two cases so one
case is it's the right-hand side of a
rule
right
another case is something like map
if i'm not mistaken
right i mean certainly your go
to your your go-to guides are going to
be replace replace all replace repeated
map
already does this
what
with already does this
okay so the question is what functions
well with with the
width combined with condition
what do you mean with combined with
condition what what
uh you
oh well oh that's what you mean right
right well yes well with right it let
yes it lexically replaces x with value
right so with already does it
which is the same thing
that you know the slotty thing does
right
template slot and so on would also do
that
okay so
this is where we should be looking
so now
um
of these
i'm not even going to imagine what
nothing does in the case of unevaluated
expressions
i mean these
yeah okay so there's another case here
okay
okay so eg reverse
want to
apply
a
function to the top level of an
expression structure
but not below
so i'm saying that's even another case
because one thing is the forward
litecoin business of as soon as you seed
it
the whole thing is is turned to
dust or whatever right as soon as you
seed the thing every sub-expression is
going to be evaluated
the other case is
that you only want to deal with the top
level of the expression
see what i'm saying like like in reverse
i can imagine that that's the thing
that's
basically impossible
i mean i know of no way to do it
even with hackery
i mean right basically the only way
no you could do it for specifically
reverse by wrapping and unwrapping the
arguments
so for example okay let's say
let's say so so this could be
a
top level only apply of f
okay and what does it do it wraps
oof onto g of x y z
okay wraps
x y z
does the operation
gets out
unwraps
that would be how you would do it
right
yes so it's kind of like a yeah
or yeah i mean and of course there are
very variations of this like sliding and
unevaluated in the right place and then
releasing to hold um but yes there's
sort of no way to do this in a single
step right you you have to do it in sort
of three steps well but basically what
you have to do and this is sort of an
interesting concept is the wrapping and
unwrapping business
in other words what you're doing is
this is sort of a with held wrapping
you know which says
wrap some sub-expressions
do an operation
then unwrap
i don't think this is completely i mean
look look
what i'm pretty convinced of at this
point is that there's nothing there's no
slam dunk we just need one idea we're
going to solve everything this is the
thing where we're going to have to do a
certain amount of you know but the
question is can we make a somewhat
intuitive interface to the this gingerly
touching
things that might otherwise explode
so within a held expression
by the way i mean we need to understand
you know within a health expression
first thing is we want some kind of
immediate evaluate
okay so immediate evaluate
would normally
um
normally
immediately evaluate
of exper
just evaluates everything inside exper
so
let me put it this way so rule first
evaluates the matches then inserts
rule delayed is first matches then
inserts then evaluates and there's a
third possibility only one third
possibility which we are missing which
is first matches then evaluates then
inserts okay hold on so you're saying
you're saying
so i i said again
so there are only three three things to
worry about
evaluating matching and inserting
okay so let's evaluate
match
and insert and and match always comes
before insert
so there are only three possibilities
not six
okay so then what you're saying what are
you saying you're saying replace
is evaluate
match and insert
rule delayed
is match
insert
and evaluate
and we are missing a third rule which is
rule condition what rule condition does
which is match
evaluate
and insert
you're right
you're right
that's nice
okay
well that would be a very doable thing
to put that in
i mean whether it's a a sort of a
wrapper for rule delay which is what i
kind of prefer but okay but so so that's
that's that case but now
now we've got to now
now consider
nuances
to evaluate
right in other words is it all the way
down
you got what i'm saying this isn't just
for rule i mean
it probably has to be all the way down i
mean because
what what well i'm understanding that in
this case
i'm thinking of this case
right the nuance is instead of just hold
of look look what this is
is
withholding
withholding
where
no um
apply withholding
of f
onto x spur
okay
and and what that would do
is this thing that i'm saying above here
so apply withholding
would say basically
um
it would be uh
you know f
of
well this thing here right i mean if i
say
i mean here let's let's write it a bit
more explicitly h of
args triple blank
and what that would be is
f
of
h
oh my god how to do this well i mean
this is going to be held inside
and so this is some kind of weird right
so it'll need to be
yeah
some kind of sequence inside there where
you're mapping
hold to
um
right you'd need to
to map hold on to unevaluated of list of
args
okay but so you've got to do various
horrifying things here and then when
you're finished with this
you would map
you would map
hold of x of x blank goes to
x uh across the result
i don't even understand that but anyway
yeah it's very simple hold of x blank
goes to x
and uh or replace it level one sorry
this thing replaced that at level one
you're saying is that what you're saying
yep and then then it's hold of the whole
thing
otherwise the whole thing's going to
blow up
uh
well i guess i was assuming that a h was
already
no
no because this is inside this whole
thing is within the whole point is that
this is inside an immediate evaluate
the immediate evaluate is an apply
withholding
okay well then i guess you'd need uh
it's a little bit more complicated but i
think we all agree that there's a
there's a thing you could do here where
you basically um you know
evaluate
with inner wrapping
i hadn't really thought of this before
that we could have a systematic way of
inner wrapping but we might have to
define
uh you know where you wrap
eg levels
part numbers
etc
where you wrap it auto wraps and then it
auto unwraps in other words it treats ie
treating
certain sub
as atomic
during the operation
and that's the key idea
so what you're saying is one key idea is
that we evaluate before inserting
i'm claiming another key idea is
we are doing evaluations in which
certain sub-expressions are treated as
atomic
i think both of these things are quite
useful
um
free on that livestream else is a good
reason why one does not want to replace
on levels whose depth is a prime or
something similarly arbitrary
only solution i can see the functions
applied
all over the ast but has access to a
means to evaluate a different local and
global scope
why is it difficult to evaluate to i
mean why can't you just do a map at
onto
what why don't you just get
well i mean it's a little bit messy but
i i would think you could do
a map at
onto the
do does mapat allow patterns
but can you do that can you say map at
of abcd
i don't think so replace part does but
nothing yeah replace part does
um yeah so you can't use a pattern that
says
two blank or something
right no
i mean the extensions we've talked about
with map at
uh that works
so universal patterns work
uh
uh no uh a few universal patterns work
very fine or it's or is map or is map
maybe the map map it is the one
exception that does every every right
well we've talked about this the last
few months and making all these fun all
these ad functions consistent
so i guess yes and i think replace part
is the
unusual one and it does very well with
patterns replace part can do arbitrary
patterns because it's only dealing with
parts it's not dealing with expressions
that could explode
um all right we should wrap up here we
are making progress finally with this
inert expressions question i think i
think we've got a limited number of
functions here like
you know
immediate evaluate or whatever we call
it and like this evaluate with
withholding
these are both i think interesting and
useful things
whether activate part is useful that
might also be useful
but we've basically got two branches
here
you know we've got two fundamental
branches
right is is activate part any different
from
map at activate expression come apart
i was about to say if you combine it
with the immediate evaluate than it is
okay it's like a map out of and
immediately evaluate and activate
right
but so we've got two basic branches and
activate
which is you know inactivate
uh sprays
i don't know what protection you know
sprays
uh
pixie dust
no no it's freezing things what is the
right it's like what is that carbon what
the heck is that called the carbonite
the thing that uh that han solo went
into yeah right sprays carbonite
um
everywhere onto all subparts
whereas
but leaves but but leaves the overall
structure exposed
whereas hold
puts a
i don't think this
oh it's very confusing puts a a um
a boundary
you know a protective boundary around
everything
but as soon as you extract anything
but as soon as you pull everything out
anything out it'll blow up
but the subparts are not protected
yeah well i i think we're making real
progress here this is great
let's let's bring this back another time
i i really think this is this is
promising i think we should think
through these these two cases basically
okay i don't know whether this is a
principle thing the supply withholding i
kind of think that there is a principal
way to do this
i never thought of this one before
because that would allow right but if
you're oh well good
i got
right well i guess the problem is
i don't know that this necessarily goes
into
immediate evaluate i think it maybe is
its own thing right because you do
it's a separate function
right okay right in which case it
doesn't need to wrap the hole because
the holding will come from
[Music]
the outer thing so you could say
immediate evaluate of apply withholding
right
no you couldn't no no no no not that but
i'm
right but i'm saying that apply
withholding would probably need to be
also specially treated by the function
that's interpreting things just like
immediate evaluate
fair enough hey listen for every
purposes this is in the code
transformation subfolder
yep i got it thank you
okay well to be continuing another time
uh stuff thanks and thanks to folks on
the live stream see